Corée du Nord les hommes du dictateur
une enquête journalistique signée par
marjolaine grappe et qui révèle donc
l'existence d'une administration secrète
sous l'autorité directe de Kim junghe
chargée de se procurer des devises
étrangères en contournant allègrement
les sanctions internationales devises
qui permettront entre autres de financer
le programme d'armement nucléaire
nord-coréen nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débadoc avec vous tout
d'abord Olivier Guyard bienvenue à vous
vous êtes chercheur associé à l'Institut
de géopolitique appliquée et on vous
doit entre autres ce livre que faire
avec la Corée du Nord point
d'interrogation subir
enir ou punir point d'interrogation à
nouveau un ouvrage publié aux éditions
nubis Marianne perron d'Oise est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
chercheuses associés à l'Iris Institut
des relations internationales et
stratégiques bien sûr
et directrice de l'Observatoire
géopolitique sur l'Indo pacifique et
puis enfin avec nous Philippe Le Corre
bienvenue vous êtes professeur invité à
l'ESSEC et chercheur à l'asias Society
Policy Institute vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'Asie du Sud-Est et en
particulier du monde chinois on va
commencer par une carte pour resituer la
République populaire démocratique de
Corée c'est le nom de la Corée du Nord
bien entendu elle est située au nord de
la péninsule coréenne située bien sûr en
Asie du Sud-Est le pays compte quelques
25,3 millions d'habitants c'est la
moitié de son voisin du Sud sa capitale
est Pyongyang et regardez ces frontières
au nord celle avec la Chine
1416 km de frontières communes au nord
du pays donc de la Russie également au
nord-est avec 19 km de frontières et
bien sûr de la Corée du Sud qui elle
compte quelques 238 kilomètres de
frontières cette dernière frontière
méridionale et bordée de part et d'autre
par 2 km de largeur par la zone des
milliatives des militarisés pardon la
fameuse DMZ dont il est évidemment
question dans le documentaire que nous
venons de voir qui est surveillé cette
frontière par quelques un million de
soldats à la fois du côté du nord et du
côté du Sud Olivier Guyard ce qu'on
apprend pour l'essentiel dans ce
documentaire et pour faire simple c'est
qu'en réalité il y a deux économies
celle de la famille Kim et l'économie
nationale dirigée par le gouvernement
central
c'est tout de même pas rien non si vous
permettez peut-être un petit mot pour
dire tout le bon tout le bien que je
pense de ce reportage il est admirable
donc il met certainement à la
disposition du public des données qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas connues il est
très pédagogeux en tout cas donc bravo à
Marjolaine c'est un excellent travail
pour en revenir donc à votre question
effectivement donc il y a deux économies
qui se chevauchent qui sont entre
chevaux c'est un terme un peu plus
compliqué que cela l'une profite
directement au grand dirigeant à sa
famille on pourra une redresserie une
redistribution simplement en fonction de
des priorités de Monsieur et de son clan
et de l'autre côté donc nous avons cette
économie nord-coré bizarroïdes qui ne
fonctionne pas selon les lois de marché
évidemment il y a des échanges notamment
avec le partenaire commercial et grands
voisins chinois mais pas que c'est une
c'est une économie qui a plus d'entrant
que de sortants définitive pour donc
c'est une économie qui visiblement
relativement mal
elle fonctionne pas selon des modèles
connus ici en Occident c'est une
économie qui est exangle évidemment il
n'y a qu'à voir un petit peu dans quel
dans quel état de déshérence survivent
80% de la population dort quand même
aujourd'hui en mode post covid n'est pas
auto suffisant aujourd'hui il ne
serait-ce que sur le plan alimentaire
non sur le plan alimentaire il est dans
une désert en totale on pense
probablement aujourd'hui d'après les
dernières statistiques de l'ONU qu'il
devrait y avoir entre 30 et 40% de la
population qui se situe très peu de
choses près au niveau de la famine donc
imagine un petit peu on est loin de
l'autosuffisance alimentaire quand bien
même le régime prétendrait le contraire
c'est administration ce fameux bureau 39
qu'on découvre dans ce documentaire avec
des personnes des Coréens du Nord qui se
sont exilés au sud et pour témoigner
dans ce film ils ont participé à cette
administration qui remonte donc ces deux
vis étrangères directement
à la dynastie Kim parce que ça ne date
pas de ce bureau si on a bien compris ce
que nous disent ce documentaire c'est
quelque chose plus connu aujourd'hui où
ce documentaire nous permet-il de
découvrir vraiment son mode de
fonctionnement à vos yeux je pense que
ce sont des témoignages assez
exceptionnels parce que si effectivement
on a bien compris qu'il y avait une
économie parallèle qui permet à la Corée
du Nord par tous les moyens de
ramasser de récolter des devises et par
des moyens effectivement qu'on imagine
pas très pas très clair pas très
transparent pas très honnêtement voilà
échappaient échappait en effet assez
largement et là on voit effectivement la
façon assez incroyable dans le régime se
saisit de sa population pour en faire un
produit d'exportation et notamment
ramasser des deux vis ça c'est vrai que
la découverte du travail forcé en Corée
du Nord on a on en parle assez récemment
finalement dès lors que au gré des
sanctions s'est mis en place des unités
en tout cas une cellule chargée de
surveiller au sein de l'ONU là
l'application des sanctions et on a
porté un petit peu plus d'attention à
tous les éléments quel qu'il soit
nord-coréen présent à l'étranger parce
qu'on les a soupçonnés d'avoir
effectivement ce genre d'activités
illicite pour ramasser des devises moi
je me souviens d'anecdote où on parlait
des ambassades ou des délégations
officielles nord-coréenne et de trafic
de cigarettes de trafic de toutes sortes
ou de trafics de montres et donc de
petits scandales qui étaient plus ou
moins étouffés parce qu'on avait
remarqué que les diplomates nord-coréens
étaient sous pression pour se livrer par
tous les moyens des petits trafics en
profitant de la valise diplomatique par
exemple se douter de l'ampleur qui nous
est décrite dans ce film et qu'on
découvre effectivement on a une idée des
chiffres
et des sommes en devise étrangère
remonter au niveau de l'État aujourd'hui
n'est pas une idée très précise mais je
pense que les bureaux
et les services sud-coréens ont
peut-être une capacité d'évaluer le
montant au fur et à mesure que il
compare avec les avancées du programme
nucléaire nord-coré parce que tout cet
argent c'est bien que il est dirigé vers
l'achat de composantes pour faire
avancer ce régime et donc je pense que
et en tout cas je le souhaite que les
services coréens ou américain est une
vision un petit peu plus nette du volume
de ces échanges illicites vous avez vu
ok il y a un instant cette cellule mise
en place au sein des Nations Unies on va
revoir à l'extrait du documentaire et on
en parle juste après Philippe
le 29 novembre 2017 la Corée du Nord
prend tout le monde de cours testant son
premier missile capable d'atteindre les
côtes américaines Kim jongle annonce à
son peuple posséder désormais une force
nucléaire d'État
dans le même temps une course contre la
montre est engagée de New York du siège
des Nations unies d'une cellule composée
de 8 hommes de 8 nationalités
différentes expert en technologie des
missiles en finance ou encore en
transport aérien et maritime certains
viennent du civil d'autres des services
de renseignement ils travaillent dans
l'ombre avec pour mission d'assécher le
fond secret des Kim pour stopper le
programme nucléaire nord-coréen
évidemment la question que tout le monde
se pose après avoir vu un film comme
celui-là et c'est enquête journalistique
c'est de savoir comment comment la Corée
du Nord peut arriver à se financer via
ce fameux bureau 39 alors même que un
homme considérable de sanctions
internationales ont été prononcées
contre le régime vous savez c'est quand
même un état voyou depuis maintenant
plusieurs dizaines d'années ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas nouveau et donc les sources
de financement du régime je dirais du
pays dans son ensemble de toute façon
sont en grande partie des liées à des
techniques de de
banditisme international donc Marianne
parlait notamment de de des trafics de
montres mais il y a eu aussi des trafics
de faux billets par exemple c'était bien
connu de passeport on parle beaucoup de
cyberattaques également dans ce cet
excellent documentaire arnaque à
l'assurance arnaque à l'assurance
moi-même je connais des instituts aux
États-Unis qui ont été attaqués
par des par des par des équipes
nord-coréennes disons donc si vous
voulez ça n'est pas ça n'est pas nouveau
par contre ce qui est ce qui est nouveau
et ce qui transparaît de ce film c'est
que il y a effectivement une économie
parallèle qui a deux finalement deux
systèmes il y a les mais de toute façon
rien n'est transparent quand vous êtes
citoyen dans coréen vous évoluez dans un
monde orwellien dans lequel jusqu'à il y
a encore 20 ans vous n'aviez même pas le
droit d'avoir une bicyclette donc vous
posez pas de questions sur le
financement de de l'école de vos enfants
quand vous avez la chance d'en avoir ou
de l'hôpital auquel vous allez etc parce
que finalement chacun est à sa place et
même si il y a quelques sourires parfois
qui transparaissent dans ce documentaire
ce n'est pas un endroit où on prend
beaucoup de plaisir à vivre mais c'est
une société qui est comme ça qui est
réglementée et dont on sait que la
dynastie puisque c'est maintenant le
troisième du nom qui met en une et c'est
d'ailleurs la seule dynastie socialiste
qui existe au monde et Dieu
le fondateur de de qui me song le
fondateur du régime lui-même avait menti
si vous voulez sur sur son lieu de
naissance
il y a un certain nombre de mensonges
historiques qui sont qui ont été
intégrés je dirais presque à la à la
propagande du régime
qui fait que les gens ne se posent plus
de ne discutent pas la provenance des
fonds du budget etc ce sont des choses
qui sont qui relèvent de de l'état de de
ce pays maintenant là effectivement
j'imagine que si il transparaissait dans
dans le système d'ailleurs on voit on
voit des gens qui téléphone dans le
métro c'est quand même assez nouveau
autrefois même pas de téléphone puisque
je vous dis il y avait même pas moi je
me souviens dans les années 90 il y
avait pas de bicyclette privée
donc aujourd'hui ils ont droit à avoir
accès à des moyens de communication bien
entendu extrêmement censurés et on
discute pas de la politique locale il y
a un régime un parti une politique une
philosophie une armée qui est énormément
énormément de qu'évidemment énormément
de puissance et de pouvoir alors vous
parlez d'un état voyou avec des méthodes
de voyous si je vous ai bien entendu on
va revoir un autre extrait concernant la
la cybercriminalité orchestrée justement
par ce régime aujourd'hui
la Corée du Nord va pirater les
infrastructures industrielles ou
informatiques des États-Unis nous
n'avons pas les moyens d'analyser ces
données ni de les utiliser
on fait juste du piratage
mais en échange de la promesse de ne pas
partager ses données on demande de
l'argent
la Corée du Nord est une preneuse
d'otage de données informatiques c'est
devenu l'une des principales ressources
de ce programme nucléaire coréen la
cybercriminalité dans tout cela n'est
pas documenté la virgule près ou à la
colonne de tableaux Excel pour ceux qui
certains c'est qu'un des points forts
entre guillemets des sources de
financement aujourd'hui pérenne celui
des sur lesquels on a le moins de prise
c'est la cybercriminalité donc au-delà
des autres trafics mentionnés justement
les collègues tout à l'heure la
l'expertise des Nord-Coréens
certainement pas développer tout seul
certains pas acquises toutes seules de
leur côté il y a certainement des pays
voisins qui ont des expertises assez
fortes il y a des échanges mutilations
de moyens d'expertiser la Russie et la
Chine il y a pas énormément de voisins
et ce serait vraiment pas de la Corée du
Sud que j'ai choisi frontaliers du Nord
bien entendu et il est certain que le
régime s'appuie énormément avec une
certaine assurance avec une expertise
encore qui est aujourd'hui reconnu même
par les plus il y a encore plus méchant
que que des hackers nord-coréens on les
nommera pas mis se reconnaisseront
certainement ici et donc le régime a
besoin dans sa quête donc de ressources
à défaut de pouvoir fonctionner
normalement de de source illégitimes et
abondantes et sur lesquelles la
communauté a peu de prise ce n'est pas
demain que la cire culinalité
nord-coréenne sera quand même la
communauté internationale est serré de
restreindre un petit peu ses capacités
de dans quelle est importante
aujourd'hui elle sera encore plus demain
et nous avons surtout très peu de prise
dessus et nous sommes toujours en retard
nous courons toujours derrière les
civières criminelles nord-coré avec fort
peu de succès aujourd'hui
malheureusement évidemment ça a l'air
difficile de lutter entre autres contre
la cybercriminalité orchestrée par les
Nord-Coréens aujourd'hui comment
parviennent-ils à détourner tout de même
c'est ces fameuses sanctions
internationales dont on parlait tout à
l'heure vous avez des explications vous
sont les sanctions qui manquent de
pertinence ou écouter les sanctions sont
quand même assez sévères elles ont été
mises en place des 2006 un dès le
premier essai derrière elles ont été
renforcées
à chaque nouvelle essai à chaque
nouvelle incartade que ce soit nucléaire
ou essai balistiques évidemment et donc
on imagine que aux frontières il y a
quand même entre ces voisins dont on
soupçonne qu'il y a une certaine
proximité en terme politique en termes
d'empathie idéologie bien sûr on a
regardé avec beaucoup d'attention ce que
faisait la Chine si effectivement elle
respectait les sanctions s'il n'y avait
pas moyen pour elle de toujours fermer
les yeux sur certains certains
transferts et bien sûr on pense à des
transferts de d'éléments nécessaires
d'éléments technologiques nécessaires au
programme on a effectivement regardé
davantage par voie de maire et je pense
qu'il y a eu effectivement un effort
particulier sur les transbordements
maritimes là aussi et c'est extrêmement
compliqué
l'océan evaste et la Corée du Nord nous
a toujours donné
une image de pays très très industrieux
très malin et les pavillons de
complaisance font que il est facile de
cacher l'identité d'un bateau qui fait
des transferts illicites au profit de la
Corée du Nord et donc par le biais de
tous ces moyens assez mafieux assez
délicieux ben la Corée du Nord
bénéficions évidemment d'une certaine je
dirais complicité
à l'aide d'entreprises écran par exemple
vous avez on a parlé de la Chine de la
Russie le documentaire montre que la
Pologne que la Mongolie finalement ferme
un peu les yeux peut-être aussi certains
pays du Moyen-Orient quant à l'accueil
de travailleurs nord-coréens et bien on
peut imaginer aussi d'autres pays
de d'Asie du Sud-Est on a beaucoup
regardé des entreprises écran à
Singapour euh qui permettait
effectivement d'acheminer certaines
composantes absolument vitales pour pour
le régime nord-coréen donc finalement à
la fin à la fin des fins on se rend
compte que par tout un ensemble de
moyens et on bénéficiant d'une certaine
forme de complicité la Corée du Nord
elle arrive assez fin et le résultat on
le voit avec un programme nucléaire et
des capacités nucléaires qui deviennent
de plus en plus je dirais établi et
menaçante cette fameuse porosité face à
ces sanctions elle vient pour
l'essentiel de la Chine imagine la Chine
et la logique géographique la Chine
est-ce que c'est le cas à ce que cette
péninsule demeure divisée et à tout
intérêt à ce que un pays voisin comme la
République démocratique populaire de
Corée lui soit redevable et donc il est
clair que ce pays qui est un peu au banc
des nations qui menace son voisin on
sait que la fameuse frontière la DMZ est
est à 40 km de Séoul donc les
Sud-Coréens vivent sous cette épée de
avec cette épée Damoclès et donc la
Chine protège ce régime d'ailleurs
récemment les des chercheurs chinois
envisagés très bien que que la Chine
Vienne aider viennent au secours de la
Corée du Nord en cas de guerre en cas de
conflit un petit peu comme la Chine le
fait indirectement avec la Russie
économiquement peut-être à travers des
biais en tout cas à travers une
neutralité sélective la Chine cherche à
créer une sorte de d'amical des des
régimes autoritaires et n'a pas intérêt
à ce que la péninsule serait soit
réunifiée sous la houlette de la
République de Corée qui a un président
élu démocratiquement tous les cinq ans
et un mandat unique d'ailleurs ce qui
évidemment pas le cas de la dynastie des
Kim et où il y a une grande liberté de
pas des affaires de circuler y compris
de la faire de la politique Corée du
Nord qui exporte beaucoup de charbon de
tissus vers la Chine c'est du troc en
réalité quelque part entre les deux
parties c'est comme ça qu'on peut entre
les deux pays c'est comme ça qu'on peut
voir les choses on peut penser que
grosso modo avec le peu d'alternative
dans cet environnement de deux sanctions
et que l'on décrivait un instant 90% des
échanges extérieurs de la Corée du Nord
se font avec la Chine voilà la Chine
fermerait avec un peu d'autorité d'envie
ces frontières la Corée du Nord aurait
le régime pardon aurait beaucoup de mal
à s'en sortir en l'espace de quelques
mois probablement même moins ce n'est
pas le cas évidemment aujourd'hui dans
les deux sens donc ce qui est sûr c'est
que comme le propos de de mon collègue à
l'instant Pékin a un regard sur l'état
dans lequel doit se trouver une manière
d'une manière pérenne et pour encore un
certain nombre de dans cette péninsule
en deux entités aussi antinémiques une
que l'autre avec des espoirs au sud une
fois encore toujours
entre espoir et déception et réalité les
suites coréens seraient favorables à de
meilleures relations avec la Corée du
Nord la Corée du Nord de temps en temps
donc laisse croire au concert des
nations assez Olivier Washington
notamment qu'elle est prête à discuter à
faire des concessions à mettre en douce
un petit peu son ces programmes
balistique nucléaire à entrer dans une
logique de nucléarisation on n'a jamais
eu pratiquement de choses tangibles
attestant que il y avait autre chose que
des promesses qui ne seraient pas tenues
chacun sait les
nord-corens sont d'excellents joueurs
d'échec ils l'appliquent également en
géopolitique et dans ce qu'il promet et
ce qui ne donne pas la communauté
internationale et en première ligne nous
avons c'est vous qui est toujours au
rang des grands déçus il y a toutes mes
muscles que vous avez appelé dans votre
livre le printemps coréen et ça nous
ramène aux années
2018-2019 autrement dit des années Trump
du côté des États-Unis et bien sûr
qu'une du côté de la Corée du Nord ça
c'était réchauffé trois rencontres
c'était inédit la première eu lieu à
Singapour ensuite Hanoï pour la seconde
et puis sur cette fameuse ligne D pour
la troisième de ces rencontres mais
enfin ça m'était jamais vu depuis la fin
de la guerre de Corée et puis un
rapprochement aussi entre le Sud et le
Nord tout ça c'est derrière nous c'est
fini ce printemps coréen j'ai voulu
évoqué donc c'était il y a déjà 5 ans
j'ai l'impression que c'était il y a 50
ans tellement on s'est brutalement
arrêter en février de 2019 beaucoup de
déceptions du côté du de la Corée du Sud
il y avait un président à l'époque
Monsieur moujin qui était un libéral qui
a vu une vision très très fraternée des
relations entre les deux Corées avec
certains un peu de naïveté mais beaucoup
d'espoir il aurait largement mérité
d'obtenir le prix Nobel de la paix pour
son opiniâtreté ça n'a pas été récolté
de paix puisque la paix n'a jamais été
officiellement signé entre ces deux pays
exactement en 2018 donc la Corée du Sud
organisait des Jeux olympiques d'hiver
les nord-coré étaient invités une
délégation nord-coré était là à côté
d'ailleurs de la délégation de la Maison
Blanche le vice-président il y avait une
atmosphère de les choses peuvent
éventuellement se faire les Nord-Coréens
ont mis à moratoire sur le récit sur le
respect atomique à l'automne 2017 on va
les choses se mettaient relativement en
place il y avait un certain optimisme il
faut bien être optimisme de temps en
temps y compris dans cette région du
monde 4 ans plus tard cinq ans plus tard
on en est à se dire que la Corée du Nord
n'a pas bougé d'une annonce elle a de ce
qu'elle a promis elle n'a rien fait et
surtout donc elle a été ses arsenaux
nucléaires et balistiques à un point que
que l'on n'imaginait certains pas ça
compte plutôt la Corée du Nord
certainement malheureusement tristement
pour tout le monde bien joué sa partie
une fois encore donc changement de
conditions politiques Trump remplacé par
Biden le président que vous avez évoqué
sud-coréen qui lui aussi a changé depuis
pour un président beaucoup plus
conservateur donc je vais citer le nom
en pardonnant évidemment le fait que je
puisse écorcher son nom young Soke yole
c'est l'actuel président de la Corée du
Sud qui lui est un conservateur et qui a
changé de ton aussi vis-à-vis du Nord
c'est ça qui explique qui est plus de
printemps coréen suivant l'expression
qui avait utilisé Olivier Guyard en fait
il y a toujours eu une alternance quand
on regarde sur le sur le long cours avec
un régime plus ouvert un régime
sud-coréen plus progressiste enclin
ajustement mettre en avant le dialogue
inter-coréen avec toujours cette idée de
réunification de la péninsule c'est ce
sont des pays frères et effectivement il
y a toujours la tentation de revenir et
l'espoir de pouvoir apporter une
solution à cette séparation
de plus en plus et donc malheureusement
les liens familiaux ont tendance à se à
se déliter mais c'est vrai que vous vous
avez souligné que l'on avait un
président conservateur et ce président
conservateur lui la réciprocité c'est
une notion qu'il a très mis très tôt
mise en avant c'est-à-dire que à chaque
effort de la part du régime
sud-coréen et des Américains ou des
Japonais et bien en échange il faut une
compassion en fait un effort de la part
une concession de la part du régime du
régime nord-coréen et c'est quelque
chose que la Corée du Nord ne comprend
pas puisque en fait Olivier quand tu
parlais du printemps et puis d'une
certaine forme de déception j'aurais
tendance à dire que paradoxalement le
régime nord-coréen a été déçu aussi
parce que dans la logique du Cher
dirigeant allait à Singapour rencontrer
le grand ennemi américain c'était quand
même une concession absolument
extraordinaire et énorme et il mettait
peut-être son poids politique dans la
balance et il fallait toute son autorité
pour que finalement la propagande du
régime explique comment cela se faisait
que le cheerleader allait parler à cette
nation et aux représentante cette nation
qui était présentée par la propagande
comme une abomination depuis des années
donc je pense qu'il a déçu parce que
selon la logique diplomatique
nord-coréenne il y avait une énorme
concession donc à la fois ce moratoire
et puis se déplacement et cette poignée
de main et la signature d'un accord ou
finalement qui met en route parlait de
dénucléarisation c'est un mot absolument
tabou pour le régime et il l'avait
prononcé tout en disant des nucuration
de la péninsule et c'est là où
finalement il s'est senti un peu joué
parce que dans son esprit la
dénucléarisation c'est la déclinisation
de et une réduction de la présence
militaire américaine donc il y a des
efforts à attendre des deux côtés alors
côté américain justement avec l'arrivée
de Joe Biden on en est revenu à une
formule qui était valable d'ailleurs
avant l'arrivée de Trump à la Maison
Blanche on peut la résumer comme ça pas
de dialogue possible tant qu'un
processus de dénucléarisation justement
n'est pas engagée or cette cette ligne
tenue par les Américains n'a pas obtenu
de résultat par le passé peut-elle en
obtenir aujourd'hui
c'est la question que je voulais vous
poser qu'il faut vraiment être réaliste
par rapport à ce régime et que
effectivement la parenthèse Trump a été
celle d'un d'un coup de tête d'un
personnage quand même inhabituel dans la
classe politique américaine qui a décidé
de faire un deal en fait un compromis
avec le plus grand dictateur de la
planète en fait c'était ça et donc c'est
permis contre la vie de ses conseillers
du département des tas du Conseil
national de sécurité y compris ceux qui
étaient les plus proches de son régime
je parle de régime Trump d'aller
rencontrer effectivement le dictateur
nord-coréen qui lui-même était assez
jeune inexpérimenté mais voilà c'était
dit voilà moi je suis Donald Trump je
suis capable de faire ça bon bien
entendu c'était très risqué parce que
tous ceux qui parlent passé avaient
tenté de faire un deal ou un accord avec
l'un des trois Kim je dirais en sont
restés sur sur leur sur leurs frères on
fait les frais et notamment la
dénucléarisation qui avait été évoquée à
l'époque Clinton donc dans les années 90
souvenez qu'il y avait eu des pour
parler de paix qui avait eu des de
nombreux échanges y compris à Pékin on
s'était les pour parler à 6 d'ailleurs
entre parenthèses les talents de
médiateurs de la Chine à l'époque
n'avaient pas n'avait pas porté leurs
fruits donc on peut avoir des doutes sur
d'autres situations je ferme la
parenthèse mais quoi qu'il en soit les
experts de la Corée aujourd'hui disent
il ne faut pas parler à ce régime tant
que il n'y a pas vraiment des des faits
des preuves tangibles or toutes les
années qui viennent de s'écouler ont
démontré que le le programme de de Bion
de de site nucléaire ce ce faisait que
ce développé et donc que finalement ce
régime était porté par le nucléaire du
côté de la Corée du Sud à l'inverse
voilà peut-être qu'un retour de
balancier aussi le président actuel
un discours de plus en plus décomplexé
en réalité sur le nucléaire on parle
même de réinstallation d'armes nucléaire
américaine du côté de la Corée du Sud
voire d'un programme sud-coréen
nucléaire on en est là on réarme la
Corée du Sud aujourd'hui on en est pas
encore tout à fait là mais il est vrai
qu'il y a c'est votre information tout à
fait exacte donc ces derniers jours la
maison bleue donc la présidence Sud
Corinne a fait état d'une d'un
reformatage du partenariat stratégique
depuis 70 ans d'ailleurs pardon on
célèbre cette année entre Washington et
c'est où le 70e anniversaire de
l'Alliance stratégie quand on les deux
pays il y a cette occasion donc le chef
de l'État sud-coréen a dit nous allons
continuer évidemment à voir ce
partenaire stratégique privilégié avec
les États-Unis d'Amérique mais nous
allons lui donner un socle nucléaire ce
sont ses propres termes donc une
alliance qui est désormais nucléaire
probablement davantage dans les faits
pour envoyer un message donc à Pyongyang
certainement rassurer aussi une partie
de l'opinion publique et peut-être aussi
se rassurer vis-à-vis de Pékin la
relation à la Corée du Sud et la Chine
sont un petit peu compliquées entre j'ai
un peu besoin de toi au niveau
commercial économique les
investissements etc c'est un marché à
l'exportation à les 300 c'est important
mais d'un autre côté on a un petit peu
mal à l'aise donc effectivement le
président sud-coré aujourd'hui qui est
loin d'être aussi je vais dire candide
peut-être naïf voire généreux que sont
que son prédécesseur libéral a largement
c'est le ton et de plus en plus près
aussi de ce que dit Washington donc
c'est toujours un petit peu Séoul à
quelques problèmes de pour calibrer son
indépendance ou son attachement avec
avec la ligne stratégique américaine
bref donc tout ceci quoi qu'il en soit
alimente un cercle qui me semble-t-il
est malheureusement uniquement
profitable à la Corée du Nord qui est
enquête c'est pas mise autour de la
table continue à faire ce qu'elle veut
donc on multiplie comme l'évocat
Philippe à l'instant donc les une
inflation urballistique sur Alice
l'année dernière le premier semestre
2023 et pas mal non plus en termes de
prolifération en tous les cas de des
records en termes de bien entendu donc
tout ce temps
nord-coréen depuis l'année dernière
exactement tant que la Corée n'est pas
contraint de négocier et de se mettre
sur Stop elle continue est offer ses
arsenaux c'est exactement ce qu'elle
cherche à avoir et elle rejette la
responsabilité sur la Corée du Fernand
sur la Corée du Sud sur les États-Unis
sur le Japon en disant c'est ses voisins
sont hostiles ils ne sont hostile
historiquement et puis peut-être encore
davantage aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
leur faire confiance nous sommes donc
contraints si la propagande des
algorithmes Nord Corinne classique de
continuer dans cette voie on est dans
une logique d'action réaction qui fait
que on voit en fin de compte les
programmes d'armement augmenté les
budgets de défense augmenter que ce soit
du côté Corée du Sud au Japon et en fait
il y a une demande très claire de la
part de la Corée du Sud c'est un
renforcement de la garantie de sécurité
or comme l'explique Olivier en fait il y
a ce débat sur le nucléaire et le fait
que les États-Unis se sont un petit peu
laissés forcer la main devant cette
allié sud-coréen qui réclame qui peut
être menace en faisant implicitement un
chantage au nucléaire lui-même en se
disant que s'il n'y a pas de garantie
suffisante de la part du grand allié
américain et bien il sera obligé face à
une menace qui tend à se préciser non
seulement du côté nord-coréen mais aussi
on peut aussi parler de la Chine que la
Corée du Sud commence à ressentir comme
un voisin assez pesant et assez agressif
et donc à partir de là on est dans une
logique où on a l'impression de que à
chaque fois que un essai nucléaire ou
balistique ou la menace du septième
essai nucléaire puisqu'on en est on en
est là se précise et bien la Corée du
Sud ce sont un petit peu encline en
hardi à demander une garantie de
sécurité supplémentaire à Joe Biden qui
a bien été obligé de par exemple de
revenir aux escales de sous-marins
nucléaires et là il envoyait
effectivement un signal fort et je pense
que c'est c'est dans l'affichage que
effectivement réside cette
nucléarisation de la relation entre la
Corée du Sud et les États-Unis mais la
question reste posée à la fois du côté
de la Corée du Sud mais faut-il le dire
aussi du côté du Japon qui se sont lui
aussi très très menacé par la Corée du
Nord tout à l'heure la guerre en Ukraine
est-ce que ça a changé la donne est-ce
que c'est pas une bonne chose pour la
Corée du Nord sachant qu'une s'est mis
très très clairement à travers des
propos publics du côté bien entendu de
ce front antioxydantal entre la Chine et
la Russie ça peut changer la donne
est-ce que c'est pas un avantage
aujourd'hui pour la Corée du Nord dans
le contexte c'est-à-dire que vous savez
un petit peu comme dans le détroit de
Taïwan les gens se disent finalement
s'il y a une guerre plus au nord sur la
insulte coréenne quelle partie prendra
la Chine celui bien sûr de la Corée du
Nord puisque la Chine comme je disais
tout à l'heure est favorable à cette
division à cette partition entre ces
deux Corée qui existe depuis 1953 depuis
la fameuse guerre de Corée que la Chine
n'avait pas gagné
et donc elle elle est favorable à une à
une sorte de plus petit pays et donc je
pense que Pyongyang est assez rassuré
par rapport à cela par ailleurs on pense
qu'il y a sans doute des transactions
entre la Corée du Nord et la Russie
les filières nord-coréennes qui sont par
exemple on parlait de la Mongolie dans
ce documentaire bon sont plutôt des
travailleurs la Mongolie est une
démocratie mais elle est prise un petit
peu en tena et entre d'un côté la Chine
et de l'autre côté la Russie
mais donc ça il y a des gens qui passent
il y a des communautés il y a une
communauté nord-coréenne de même qu'il y
a une forte communauté nord-coréenne en
Chine et finalement il y a des citoyens
Nord-Coréens qui sont en mission
finalement on en revient au thème de
l'émission c'est à dire que vous avez
des gens des émissaires des sortes
d'ambassadeurs un peu du crime qui sont
prêts à contourner les sanctions les
sanctions qui sont prêts à faire du
trafic et éventuellement à travailler
avec d'autres États voyous pour pour
contrer les sanctions et notamment pour
contrer les sanctions contre la Russie
dans le cadre de la du conflit ukrainien
dernière question il nous reste une
minute Olivia et je sais très bien que
vous ne lisez pas dans les boules de
cristal néanmoins on a vu plusieurs
personnages apparaître sur la scène
publique nord-coréenne et c'est
important de voir des personnages sur la
scène publique ça c'est un signe envoyer
en réalité par le pouvoir d'une part la
seule et d'autre part sa fille est-ce
qu'on envisage une succession possible
et ce qu'une succession possible à Kim
juman pourrait changer la donne il est
trop tôt évidemment je pense que Kim
jong-una s'est fêté ses 40 ans son 31e
anniversaire cette année il est encore
assez jeune il ne se répand si bonne
santé que cela donc
l'agrégation de d'une hygiène de vie
certains un petit peu difficile puis un
héritage génétique un petit peu délicat
en revanche tout ça est trop bien dans
le champ de ce qu'il a la culture
coréenne et surtout la culture du
pouvoir donc cette cette dynastie
héréditaire chimiste où il s'agit de
présenter bon si jamais on a pour une
autre le le jeune maréchal actuel donc
disparaissait sachez que vous connaissez
sa soeur c'est la Numéro 2 informel du
régime elle est allée à l'étranger elle
est aussi redoutable que son frangin la
comprend que son frère pardon on la
comprend pas très bien non plus on sait
qu'elle ne fait pas que transmettre des
messages vous voyez il y a également une
descendance il y avait un tonton jusqu'à
encore quelques années qui a été bon mis
qui est passé de vie à trépas dans ce
sous les ordres de Kim Jong-un bref donc
tout ceci entretient un petit peu le le
mystère ou en tous les cas la pérennité
d'un régime dictateur d'une d'une avec
une forte hérédité et des possibilités
de succession il y a aussi c'est un
message pour tout le monde pour la
communauté internationale pour la
communauté intérieure domestique et puis
cette dynastie politique elle est là
elle est là aujourd'hui elle est là
depuis deux autres générations elle sera
là certainement encore demain c'est
apprendre un petit peu dans cette
ambiance la probablement un grand merci
vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission consacrée à
la Corée du Nord aujourd'hui vos
réactions ça sera bien entendu sur
hashtag de Badoc sur Twitter merci aussi
à sel massali qui m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission puis moi je vous
retrouverai pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]